The Legend of Zelda tears of the kingdom
is Nintendo's biggest switch game ever
based on its file size surpassing the
previous game breath of the wild and
other switch games from Nintendo and
that last part is key because if you
look beyond the first party Nintendo
games that's some of the third party
titles then you get some much larger
games for example NBA 2k23 is 53.7 gigs
on switch The Witcher is 31.5 gigs and
Mortal Kombat 11 comes in at 32.5 gigs
tiers of the Kingdom isn't larger than
those games but it does outweigh its
other Nintendo siblings Reddit user Bob
4978-135 discovered that tears of the
Kingdom has a file size of 18.2
gigabytes for comparison the biggest
switch game for Nintendo currently is
breath of the wild at 14.4 gigabytes
outside Nintendo switch file size for
games on Xbox PlayStation and PC can be
significantly larger stretching to 1 100
gigs and Beyond pre-orders for tears of
the kingdom are live right now and it's
the first Nintendo published game to
sell for 70 bucks as Nintendo is
following PlayStation and Xbox and
raising prices by ten dollars the good
news is that not every switch game is
going to cost 70 bucks according to
Nintendo it's going to be on a
case-by-case basis in other Nintendo
news the Pokemon company has officially
announced two upcoming expansions for
Pokemon scarlet and violet the hidden
treasure of area 0 will be released in
two parts with part one the teal mask
arriving in Fall 2023. part 2 is
scheduled for winter 2023 in both DLC
Adventures will expand beyond the
borders of the paldeo region par one
story will take place in the land of
kaitakami as players embark on a field
trip visiting a land of tranquil natural
expanses local Legends and a colorful
Festival where new Pokemon can be
encountered part 2 story unfolds in
blueberry Academy as players explore the
institution as part of an exchange
program both expansions will have over
230 Pokemon to capture from previous
generations if you can't wait that long
for new Scarlet and violet content well
you're in luck because there are Terror
raids featuring new Paradox Pokemon
starting today February 27th Pokemon
Scarlet will get walking waves a suicune
paradox Pokemon with a Terra water type
on Pokemon Violet will get iron leaves a
virision paradox Pokemon with a terror
type of psychic an update is also coming
today that will add Pokemon go support
letting you send postcards from go to
Violet and Scarlet but the most
important news of Pokemon day has to be
the new details about the long dormant
game Pokemon sleep which was first
announced in May of 2019 and it's the
most important because I just really
love the meme of it all and I can't
believe it's actually a thing still
Pokemon sleep is a game created around
the play players sleep habits which will
be measured and analyzed in order to
progress through the game a slumbering
Snorlax appears on the screen when the
player first goes to sleep but it will
be joined by other sleeping Pokemon
throughout the night and multiple sleep
Styles can be collected based on the
Pokemon that appear during the night are
you excited for Pokemon sleep or the
Pokemon scarlet and violet DLC or
Pokemon go plus plus that I didn't even
mention in this video what a what a
great name for it um let me know in the
comments below and I'll see you tomorrow
thank you